and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review
the social network degraded will we have
ever seen in my life will you accept my
spoilers there's this college girl who
breaks up with this college boy the end
he goes and creates Facebook okay okey
let's bet the entire story but it's sort
of is this girl breaks up with this boy
and he's like that reminds me I should
be a millionaire so he makes this
website we compare which girls are
hotter and it totally crashes the hybrid
computer system he crashed the hybrid
computer system once with my Prius
so he's two Harvard guys see what he did
and they're like awesome you're like
what you do don't you
yeah yeah so we were like you at the
butt get our website prawns and a
grateful guy is like okey but do you
mind if I steal it and make billions of
dollars off beat certainly that'd be way
too late
oh the Facebook guy goes up to his old
girlfriend and says I'm famous you want
me no I'm fine I don't want you anyway
do you want me now no fine fine bitch so
he has this best friend who's giving him
lots of money and the friend is like I
give you all this money as long as you
say you promise not to screw me very
well you promise not to screw me what do
you think you serve wait do it click the
Facebook guy comes across the person who
founded Napster and then after guy is
like I changed everything I
revolutionize the internet and I like
yeah but now musicians lawyers and
copyright Nazis are on our asses when I
told you I changed everything
prick other guy has a wonderful idea
make lots of monies clear my friend and
make lots of money
loosen is for money so he takes away all
the best friend stocks and makes tons
and tons of money so it's just a freak
book guy in the master guy but then the
Napster guys like there's just one tiny
little problem with me yeah what
so the Napster guy gets arrested for
that the best friend is like I'm suing
your ass and then the Harvard guys are
like Bowling Green we should still his
eyes yeah but by the end the Facebook
guys thanks to its ethics the and gives
them a ton of money boo yeah but it
doesn't matter because the Facebook guy
is the world's youngest billionaire and
yes Prince must face time seeing if his
ex-girlfriend will accept my facebook
what a loser
though I guess I shouldn't talk I free
fuck my ex-girlfriend everyday that is I
slammed my face into a book hoping
you'll get her attention it does not so
the social network is a really really
good movie in fact it sort of gives me
an idea
I should sue the Facebook guy you know
the people on Facebook have like
thousands of friends that they never see
I was doing the years before they did
even here's one of them right now hello
Vanessa oh those babies I keep you see
baby this is jittery boom see what at
least except my friend request I promise
my snow won't come through your computer
you